Hi, howdy, how's it going?
How you guys doing?
Boy, boy, boo.
Hello everybody.
Sick.
I'm sick.
I'm sick two times in the same month what the heck thank you
for all the memberships thank you everybody thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you I'm back I'm back for a
little bit before I travel but hopefully next time I'll be a
vacation for me.
Japan really had it out for me for so real.
Oh, sorry.
For real.
Lexi, thank you for the pink.
Amy, thank you.
Thank you, Mimi.
Healing beams.
I was watching you earlier play that.
What's it called?
That game.
The locked room.
The escape room.
The escape game.
Yeah.
I just got back from Japan it was a little bit of a trip
from hell for me it was a little bit of not fun it was fun
and not fun I wish I could tell you guys more stories but I
will tell stories but many of it was me lying in bed like a
sick and child and today I might play a game a very easy
game I've been wanting to I had that my voice zoo game I
wanted to play it while I was gone I was like I could play
that today it's easy something I don't know we'll just chit
chat for a bit first and oh yeah Tomodachi live demo is out
I don't have a switch to I don't I don't have it.
I don't have a Switch 2.
I can't play Apocopia.
Oh wait, it's on Switch 1.
Also, can you guys see my chat is like broken?
See how like everything's cut off?
Misty Boss, thank you!
YouTube changed something and now my chat CSS is all off.
If you send a really long message, hold on, let me just, uh,
I'm just getting, hello, my name is Minto Fantome, and I am
a ghost maid, and this is a long message to test my chat
CSS.
It will break and look funny, ha ha, not ha ha funny, uh,
other, other funny, and no, don't do it before me.
Don't do it before me.
Stop!
It's me.
I'm supposed to test it.
And here, watch this.
Look!
It's all broken.
Wow.
Really long message.
See, it works fine.
No.
For some reason, that made me think of rocky from from look
it's broken everything's bro why are you guys copying and
pasting my message don't make me i can't laugh where i go
stop
breaking it stop breaking it chat being broken cannot hide
the fact that me though is very Very, very, very, very,
very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very, very,
very, very cute.
I love her.
I love you too, Gopal.
Thanks.
Okay.
I think I'm all right.
So basically, I got to Japan.
Literally the first...
Did you hear that sip?
Golly.
Hold on.
Let me try again.
again I am I at the beginning of this month I touched down
in Japan I was walking around checking out the area I had
not stayed in this area before so I was like okay I'm gonna
look around and I did and then that night I was like I
started coughing and then the next day body chills and then
the next day fever and then the next day congestion and
every day I woke up and I had something new I was like whoa
what am I gonna develop today so my first week and a half in
Japan I was very sick everyone was saying I got the flu I
don't know I don't feel like I got the flu but maybe with a
fever and body chills maybe and it was so bad that every day
and so medicine in japan it's like they kind of like target
usually like one thing they do i think they do have over
like you know medicines that are like for for everything but
it's i guess getting the the ones that target one thing are
more effective you know what i mean and so i go and i first
get thing for body and body aches why am I body ache I'm
dead you might be wondering because um being a ghost is just
absolute pain that's why I say you don't want to be a ghost
and so um I get the first one come back a Victorian child in
bed and then go to the next day get the same i get another
thing for another symptom super chats work so if you want to
send long messages send them like this no thank you though i
meant to ghosts can feel things oh yeah oh yeah don't
haven't you ever heard of like the ghosts that relive their
deaths and stuff those are the dumb ones those are the
stupid ghosts that relive their deaths but they feel it you
know medical team has acquired you some funds for throat
laws and just they kill now those don't really help though
but thank you played so many games with cannibalism she got
withdrawals but uh so sorry oh my goodness I sound so
terrible.
I, uh, what was I saying?
Hold on, let me turn down the BGM a little bit.
Yeah, uh, basically, I went to the pharmacy so many times
that the lady recognized me.
She was like, wait a second.
Didn't you get medicine like yesterday for something else?
And it's like, it's not my fault!
It's not, because basically how you get medicine in Japan is
when you buy it when you buy it you have to talk to the
pharmacist at the at the at the place right and so they're
just they're like they'll ask you questions they'll be like
they'll be like is are you the one taking this or is someone
else taking this uh are you uh have any allergies uh do you
have any questions yeah yeah they force you to have a short
consultation exactly exactly and so they recognized me and i
was like they're not like they were like you're not stacking
the medicines are you and I was like no no they were like
okay well be careful I was like but yeah it snowed one day
in while it was there and I was laying in my hotel bed
looking out the window at the snowfall and I was like Wow,
what a lovely last day on earth.
If I were a Victorian child, this is where I'm Ryan Gosling
dying in the snow.
Which, speaking of that man, have you guys seen Project Hail
Mary?
Oh my gosh, Fistop, thank you!
I'm a coughing baby.
I won't say so much about it because I don't, I don't, I, I
went in.
I watched only the trailer.
I kind of went on a whim because I was like, oh, this looks
interesting.
Um, so I didn't know anything about it.
And holy cow, it was so it was so good.
The trailer spoils a lot.
It did not at all, actually.
Though at least the one that I watched.
I just watched a trailer.
You're seeing english or japanese i saw it in english
because unless you know every scientific term in japanese
you will not understand the movie and with my sicko brain i
was like i don't want to think about japanese it had
subtitles so but oh my gosh having no expectations and just
kind of going in I saw last night was really good thanks.
I saw I saw you say that to Argo.
I saw you send that don't know I'm glad you liked it, too.
Argo, thanks for the five gifted But yeah, it's it was so It
was so good.
It was so so oh my gosh It was so good.
Yeah, I did hear that Korone and Marina in the Japanese
version, but Who do they play?
Are they like some of Rocky's voices?
I didn't read the book either.
No, I went in completely blind.
I was just like, oh yeah, I have nothing to do today.
I'm sick.
What can I do when I'm sick?
Sitting in the back of a dark movie theater?
Oh, they play The Students.
Oh, that's funny.
I'm a new arrival.
My friend Gage, who properly introduced me to you, just
started a new job.
He wanted me to send a message.
word of motivation from his kamiyoshi.
Oh, hold on, let me cough.
Okay.
Good luck.
uh, pee on their dime.
How's the saying go?
Uh, uh, the, the, the boss is making money and I will pee on
it.
Or something.
I will,
How does it go?
How does
it...
It's true, that's what they say.
Okay, well soon.
Thank you!
Thank you, that girl!
I asked out the cutie at the sandwich shop and got a...
Not a no, which felt like a no, and I'm getting...
Going through with it.
Oh no!
Sometimes they can be shot.
But you tried, you shot your shot.
Good job.
You shot your shot.
Boss makes a dollar.
I make a dime.
I mean, a dime, sorry.
That's why, wait, get paid to pee on a company time.
Welcome back, Vito.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I specifically recommend the Project Hail Mary audiobook.
Oh, yeah!
I did actually look into either reading it or listening to
the audiobook.
It's really good.
It's so good.
My boss makes a dime.
I make a dime.
My birthday was this past Saturday.
Tiaki!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday.
I honestly don't know how long today's stream will be
because it just depends on how I'm feeling.
But yeah, Project Hail Mary.
So good.
And the movie does not... It uses very limited... Very
little CGI.
screen no blue screen for the most part like it's kind of
insane i would i've been looking at like uh behind the
screen stuff or behind the behind the scene sorry behind the
scene stuff i was thinking rocky looked so great and it's
because he's a puppet oh my god amaze amaze amaze so good
yeah seriously like just it fell it fell and the soundtrack
was so good the movie was so good it was i like i just
recommend it so much a puppet controlled by five people at
once it's so it's it's so good more hope core movies please
right It was like, you know, it's, it's funny because I went
in thinking that it would just be so sad because that's like
Ryan Goslings.
I also accidentally called him Ryan Reynolds.
I'll let you guys know.
But, uh, um...
Hi.
Uh...
I can't get the names right at all.
I can't get them right at all.
Too many famous Ryan's.
But...
He's like, his cup of tea is sad, sad movie, right?
But it's a little sad.
But it's mostly Hope Corps.
And it was so nice.
The ending was so good.
It was so good.
Oh my gosh.
It was, I was, I was like, oh my gosh, this might be like
one of my favorite movies of like I don't know a long time a
long time like it was I don't know I just really liked it it
was like witty enough and serious enough you know how I like
that kind of stuff where it's like silly but also serious
halo thank you so much for the pop good the book is by the
same author as the Martian which also got a pretty good
movie adaptation I didn't see that one actually this is a
glowing review.
I've been just non-stop thinking about it.
It's just so good.
Yeah, the humor is so silly.
Hope you feel better soon.
Thank you.
Yeah, you would love the Martian.
I don't know.
Maybe I like Ryan Reynolds in the movies or something.
But I don't know.
I feel like I've watched a lot of them at this point.
Um, but yeah, so, I was sick.
Hold on.
I'm going to go through my...
Let me go through some of my, uh, pictures.
I know Doki said to ask me about the coins, and I will get
there.
Probably my favorite in years.
I never have time to go to the movies lately, though.
be saying a lot.
Me neither.
I also, when I watched Zootopia 2 for the first time, I
watched it in Japanese.
Every time I've been going to the movies lately, it's been
in Japan.
but, I watched it again.
It was on the plane.
And I watched it.
And it pissed me off again.
I don't like Zootopia 2.
That movie sucks.
Sorry.
She said you.
Dragged her to the collab cafe.
I might have said, Hey, let's go infiltrate my cafe.
Oh, what I hate about Zootopia 2 is Judy Hopps ruins that
movie.
Say it, Queen.
She is so...
I'm going to say it.
gonna say it she's a bitch and i don't like it she is so
mean the whole movie and then there's no she doesn't pay
there's no character development
i don't i said it again go off queen i'm speaking my truth
i've watched that movie twice now and it's And it's just so
stupid.
It's so dumb.
What else did I watch?
I watched Legally Blonde.
That movie's great.
I watched that movie.
What else did I watch?
I watched Five Nights at Freddy's 2.
And that movie...
That...
Yeah, there's a second Five Nights at Freddy's movie.
also made no sense.
It's so
um it was uh it made no sense.
It was okay like the most the most baffling part about it
was like these I don't know what grade she's in.
She looks like she's in middle school.
These sixth graders are...
Yeah, I did watch the first one.
I did watch the first one.
Um...
Did you think it was better than Zootopia 2?
Yeah.
Controversial opinion.
Alert.
Uh-uh.
But...
She looks like she's...
I think she's in, like, middle school, right?
She's, like, in 6th grade.
And, like, the sister of...
Oh, gosh.
What's his name?
Pita from Hunger Games.
I don't remember what his name is, though, in the movie.
The security...
Security Man.
Is 6th grade middle school?
It is in...
The United States.
but anyway he has like a sister and she she's she's in
school and she's in like this robotics class and she has
this teacher who's like we gotta win the science fair or
else our our our school will be a disgrace we win the
science fair every year
And...
Oh yes, Josh Hutcherson.
Yes, yes, that guy, that guy.
The teacher was so mean for no reason.
She's like trying to build a robot.
And he's like, you need to build the best robot ever.
And then she brings in Chica.
No, sorry.
She brings in a little...
little robot that she made and he breaks it what sort of
science fair has that much pressure i thought this right
like i thought the science fair was everybody in the school
competes not like different schools are competing it's so
confusing yeah they were expecting metal gear wrecks oh
don't put oticon in the in the science fair I hope you feel
better soon.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
23 months, thank you, thank you.
It was just very confusing.
He does die.
Spoilers.
Mine had K through 5 is elementary, 6 through 7 is middle.
8 through 9 is junior high.
What's a junior high?
Wait, am I wrong?
Get in the spring traps, Shinji.
Yeah, I watched those movies And eat potato clocks I hope
you guys enjoyed Portal It was really fun Yeah, I did go to
some idle lives While I was in Japan There was one that I
went to And I was feeling good I was like, I was like, I'm
done with my flu I'm feeling the I'm feeling the adrenaline
The dopamine oh she looked at me it was great and then
afterwards I went to go get ramen and I took two bites of my
ramen and I was like no sorry afterwards I was like oh my
head starting to hurt a little I went to go get ramen and I
took two bites and then I was like I was like Reggie Rettro
and luckily the restaurant was right next to a bathroom
because I was literally I was floating down the hall holding
my mouth being like it wasn't funny at the time I was crying
and I get to the bathroom and I just
this really is the trip from hell oh no it gets worse let me
tell you um did uh like we did dance practice with dentatsu
for the concert and everything I was literally I was on the
ground like just like I could not I could not breathe I was
like coughing so much like it was so bad luckily it was just
you know practice and everything but I was like dang this is
this is really bad I think and then I went outside is that
crazy I went outside I forgot I have a bit of my my
ectoplasm is a bit to the Sun I have a bit of I guess you
could call it a Sun allergy I forgot about that and I got a
little bit sunburnt and then it burst into blisters
everywhere I was like mr.
boats is wild ride and then I got sick and then oh so I was
supposed to fly to carrier con and my flight kept getting
delayed kept delayed kept getting delayed until um it
delayed until I would miss my connection flight and then I
wouldn't arrive to CarrierCon until Saturday which I would
then be so jet lagged and everything so I was like okay well
I will just stay in Japan for a couple more days and then
fly I got that's where I got sick I got sick at the airport
I got sick at the airport because it's disgusting there and
i'm all blistered up and i'm sick i go to another hotel i
wake up and i have a little dot on me that itched and i was
like well that's kind of weird i don't think i would get bit
by a bug it's not really the season i
checked the mattresses i did not see any bugs But then the
day the day after I woke up covered in in more dots So
they're either Bed bugs that I brought home to my maid cafe
or or Stress hives.
I don't know And after the concert at Carrier con I was
like, okay, I'm gonna take a nap I take a nap And this is
the day.
I'm supposed to leave.
I'm supposed to Uh, go home?
Wait, no.
No, it was after my meet-and-greet I took a nap.
What?
Yeah.
After my meet-and-greet I took a nap.
I wake up.
This is the day I'm supposed to go home.
Flight's cancelled.
So my second flight got cancelled.
And...
So I had to stay another day in Japan.
At that point, too, I was like, Look, Japan doesn't want me.
America doesn't want me.
What am I supposed to do?
I got the flu.
I got cold.
I got sick twice in one month.
I got sun allergy.
I got...
My vacation...
This trip was supposed to be a short vacation for me.
And it turned into a work trip.
I...
Got hives all over.
Um...
You know, I did do some fun stuff too.
I'll post more about it on Twitter and stuff.
Some more pictures.
I got to go to my own collab cafe, which I did not get to
try any of the food before because usually for the collab
cafe, when I get there, we would have a tasting session at
the cafe before it opens.
And I was too sick to do it.
my own food.
I did take Doki along.
I was like, Doki, let's go infiltrate my cafe.
Luckily, there was like nobody there.
So it was really good.
Did you at least get to meet Gabe, Jeff?
No, I just said I didn't go to CarrierCon.
No, I didn't get to go.
My flight guard.
Yeah.
But, uh...
We went and, um...
Actually, we had hung out the day before too.
Doki and I went to get afternoon tea.
Thank you!
Iron Lung and Project Hail Mary would make a really good
double bill.
Iron Lung first as the shot and then Project Hail Mary as
the chaser.
Going through the airport with that cough, you must have
been hacking.
to the gate.
Iron Mary.
Is this going to be like the Barbie Oppenheimer?
Praying you spent all your bad luck on the rest of the year.
We'll be smooth sailing.
I sure hope so.
Gosh, it was it was a time.
And then, you know, I had some things to do as well
originally i thought i could do them when i got home but
they were like oh no i we really want you to do it sooner
rather than later so i was like okay and you know i love
vicky but her her arcade is so far from where i was staying
so for like a stream if i wanted to stream at my normal time
like this time i would i was be i would i would be up at
like 7 a.m
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Yesterday was my birthday.
Surprise!
Happy birthday!
Can this aging eyeball be selfish enough to ask for a happy
birthday?
Of course!
Happy birthday!
Oh wait, no, sorry.
I'm a liar.
Wait.
It would be more like...
Okay, so I...
No, I would get up at 5 a.m.
to get the train at 6 a.m.
And then...
It was like about an hour and a half...
I was kind of far out, so...
Wait, what time did I start streaming?
9 a.m.
10 a.m.
I think I did Fatal Frame 10 a.m.
I don't remember.
But yeah.
Well, you know, it wouldn't be a big deal.
It wouldn't have been a big deal if I...
you know if I just had to wake up early that's one thing but
being sick and having to wake up and travel and you know
while I was doing everything was kind of like the the tricky
part yeah otherwise it's just like I wake up early whatever
I honestly had no issues at the waking up early part that
was that's what was frustrating for me though I was okay
waking up early but streaming was just so like oh gosh it
was yeah so I really apologize and I I feel like I do this
every time I'm so angry that I'm like okay I prepared a
script a streaming I almost said screaming a streaming
schedule for myself for while I'm gone I bought a whole new
setup and then everything explodes I'm sick of it I'm I
really thought I was like oh my gosh if if these are if
these are bed bugs I'm gonna crash out I'm gonna crash out
for real it'll be it'll be my it'll be the cherry on top of
this shit cake I can't stand it anymore but luckily there
was a portal so um hope you guys enjoyed that I had a lot of
fun playing it so yeah yeah yeah Yeah, I hope they're just
hives.
I'm looking at my tummy.
I'm covered in dots.
It looks like I have a chicken box.
I really hope things turn around for you soon.
Please take care of yourself.
You too, Brandon!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
If the pattern is random, it's not bed bugs.
Oh, really?
It looks... Wait, how... What's a... What's not random?
Wait...
Oh,
like straight lines.
Oh, no, it's random!
Wait, I didn't know that!
Oh!
Okay!
Then I think I'm safe!
Yippee!
Well, okay, there... I do have two that... Or I do have
three that are in a line.
On my length.
Those ones actually itch.
I was lucky and got tickets to this...
To this show, I'll see you and everyone else in San Jose!
Thank you very much!
Congrats on almost selling out on the Denso 2 live tickets,
only accessible seats left.
Excited to see who your special guest is gonna be, also get
well-suited.
Thank you, Ducky!
I hope they get announced soon.
No bed bugs, only cartoonishly sick.
I feel like...
I feel like I'm being dramatic.
But I don't know.
It really is cartoonishly.
It was just cartoonishly one thing after another.
Like, I wish I could make this up.
Can I have you on my Itasha?
But have you drawn in a particular pose that some people may
have opposite opinions with?
Huh?
What's the pose?
the series of unfortunate events seems sussy yeah it does
seem sussy I'm confused I'm confused
what else should I do um let's see I went I got pancakes I
got hotcakes a couple times Sounds like you had a very
stressful trip, Minto.
It was.
It was pretty, yeah.
I, um...
I can't say that I entirely enjoyed my trip.
I think being around...
Denzetsu helped a lot.
But it is not a trip that I would have wanted to revisit
twice.
Oh my gosh One thing was there was a Giver Exhibit in Akiba
that I got to go to It was like the last day And I was
passing by And I was like Whoa Giver And they had cute
little Giver plushies I have a little Giver Well I've never
seen Okay So I got it So that whenever I see David Hader
next.
It'll be, I don't have something, I don't have I don't have
something Metal Gear this time.
I have a little guy for good.
A little guy for...
Can I get some good luck?
From, from me?
Wait.
Did you hear my story?
Um.
Wait.
Did you hear about everything that I've been through this
month?
got luck left or wait it's also my birthday last week you've
sung a birthday song last year so this is just a thank you
is it now happy birthday they might take your bad luck yeah
you might it's the he wants the last bit of luck keeping you
with I
I'm gonna go to the to the light If you take any more of my
luck.
Please.
Please have me exist a little longer.
I can't even speak.
But yeah, I got some really awesome pictures from the Guyver
exhibit.
I'll post those on Twitter later too.
But I don't have not seen Guyver yet.
From what I understand from the exhibit, it's really
gorgeous.
and he really likes to flash his tit there's one little tit
he kind of like just opens it up he's like take a look can
someone explain what that is about if you know Guyver hold
on let me get a picture of it I'm sure I got one of him
flashing no way did I not get a picture of him flashing no
way there's gotta be one oh I doubt okay there's one
The chest particle cannon?
That must be it.
But he's just like flashing it.
God forbid someone have a hobby.
Isn't that where his laser comes from?
Wow.
That's his beam attack thing.
It really, though, the exhibition was so awesome.
It really made me want to like...
Get into it.
The figures were incredible.
Hold on, I'll show you him flashing his teeth.
There's one boob.
And then there were figures of a girl with actual boob out.
He had his bob out.
His bobs and knobs.
Actually, no, she had her bobs and knobs out.
This is probably the laser that everyone else is describing
underneath.
Hold on, let me double check this photo.
Actually, I'll just crop it so you can see.
Wee, wee, wee,
wee.
It was just so common that I was like, wow, he's really...
Actually, I will show this full picture because the dinosaur
is crazy.
Look at this, look at this, look at this.
Oh.
Big.
These were really huge figures.
They were so large.
Look at the dinosaur.
Why is he standing on a T-Rex?
So cool.
It looks so cool!
No, but look at this guy.
Giver.
Look at Giver right here.
He says, you want to peek?
You want to peek?
Pretty underrated classic.
It was a really cool exhibit.
It was really awesome.
You can see that guy.
You can see the T-Rex.
And he was like, yeah, I killed that guy.
I...
There was literally, like, decapitation.
I was like, that's not even allowed in Japan.
It was awesome.
Catch any Rakugo stuff.
I didn't.
Rakugo, where?
Yeah, I'll ask David Hader what the flashing is about.
It's classic 80s gore.
Heh heh heh heh.
Yeah, it's Giver.
I got a... I'll take a picture of my little Giver plush that
I will have a...
That I will have...
Um...
David Hater sign one day.
Whenever I see him next.
No!
I was just going through my photos.
And I saw a...
A outfit I wanted to buy.
I forgot to go buy it.
Since the topic of Itasha's game of I want to ask if it
would be okay to put...
For us to put...
My socials?
I wanted to ask, first, since some have concerns with
impersonation, etc.
Oh, no, I really appreciate that.
Thank you, thank you.
At least you got to go through TSA.
I had no idea that things were so bad at the American
airports.
I've been completely logged off of everything.
So I had no idea.
But...
that was so mean and I know he was mean because people
behind me were also complaining about him and he was not TSA
he was part of the airline and basically I was doing I was
going back through I was going through customs in this in
the US and they had me recheck my luggage and I was doing
that and I put it on I I put it on the belt, and the guy was
like, I almost was like, I kind of want to, I wish I got his
name.
I was like, I don't want to be a Karen, but like, I wasn't
the only one complaining about this guy.
People in line were also like, that guy was such a jerk.
He had no reason to be talking to people like that.
And he was, he literally, so basically, I put my luggage
down, and I put it down the way that, like on the belt, I
put it down in the way that I did in Japan.
Which I was a mistake because he was like he looked at me
and he was like um he was like you Your suitcase needs to go
like this he was like like this and then he like grabbed my
suitcase and like flipped it up in the air And like let it
slam down on the belt and I was like I was like I was like
uh Okay, sorry which like if you're sick of telling people
what to do get a different job because you know new people
are walking up every time and are not going to know what to
do and then when I was waiting in line for security people
that people behind me were just like yeah that guy was like
flipping people's suitcases it was so mean
like you know I was like I understand some people are gonna
have a bad day sometimes and maybe the airports are a little
chaotic and everything I mean airports are chaotic in
general right but I was like dang I'm glad because I had
moved my my travel PC and everything out of that suitcase
and put it into my into my other one I was like it's a good
thing I did because I was scared Yeah, they're a mess on
their best days, so true.
Take all of Mito's bad luck and give it to that guy.
It was so mean.
And it wasn't even a, it wasn't even like a TSA or person.
It was, like I said, someone from the airline, he was
wearing the airline's uniform.
So I was like, excuse me, mister.
Not being very nice.
No.
He's the one that ripped up Tsuki Hime.
He's probably the one!
He's the one that cut it up!
We're gonna find this guy!
Hire the Etsy witches to get that guy!
That guy needs to chill!
Oh, man.
Not the Tsuki Hime Shrutter.
That person is still going to sleep every night.
Without a guilty conscious.
Conscious.
We'll curse him.
Witch itch.
He can't reach on his...
Oh!
Witch itch he can't reach on his back!
spells?
Ah!
Kahn science.
Kahn...
I didn't say that word.
I don't know.
Yeah.
You know what the worst, or rather, you know, if someone
does ill to you, wish hemorrhoids upon them.
It's harmless, but also So...
Terrible.
Minto, no?
Why not?
That's what I was always told to do.
Wish hemorrhoids upon the person.
I didn't know Minto was this evil.
I was taught that.
I'm an evil ghost, so maybe.
Poor guy just woke up on the wrong side.
Have some mercy.
Yeah, well, I...
My trip woke up on the wrong side and chose violence against
me.
It's shrimp.
See, thank you so much.
Thank you for those who were tied.
And the five get did.
Thank you, thank you.
I cast Testicular Torsion.
Weep, weep, weep, weep, weep, weep, weep.
that's the sound
I heard that in like a Tom and Jerry oh Tom and Jerry Doki
was showing like some Tom and Jerry figurine that she got
like some random blind bag thing gotcha bag thing but
basically so Doki and I we went to tea and then the next day
we went together to my collab cafe and that was the intended
voice.
I totally got you.
I got you.
But for afternoon tea, you know, we split the bill and she's
like, hold on.
I've got coins.
And I was like, what do you mean by that?
And she just like fists her bag and reach and pull out just
a handful of coins and throws them on the table and I was
like no no no no no and she she's like all right and she
starts counting she's like 10 20 30 40 50 all the way up to
a hundred and then she goes that's one dollar and And she's
like, sorry, I have to keep the hundreds because I want to
do more gacha.
And then,
and then later that night, before, the day before, so the
next day we were going to go meet at the collab cafe.
And she messages me a terrifying threat.
And she just says, I found more coins.
And I'm like, my bag was so heavy and so full of
coins.
It was terrifying.
There were so many coins.
And then she paid for the collab cafe in coins.
Minto dragging her purse Truly Minto is carrying coins Minto
versus carrying coins A very one-sided fight Let's just say
I went to many Vending machines
After that I wish I could give you the super chat And coins
too Why, why are you like this?
But also I was like, why do you have so many coins?
And she would be like, she would be like, I just go to the,
to the, uh, Combeini.
Actually, she doesn't say Combeini.
She doesn't know that word.
She's like, I go to the convenience store and I reach into
my bag and I grab the coins.
And then I just throw them into the machine.
And then she's like, it counts them for.
me yet she still had so many coins just the slimyest coins
these aren't in coins right oh my gosh panda thank you gosh
gupple thanks for the thirts
my body knew that was a lie and rejected it i was eating
some chicken noodle soup early and it's not very good.
Sorry, my cough is so bad.
I will keep streaming.
I just hope that you guys don't hate my cough so much.
Yeah, sorry.
I gotta take some more medicine.
Need corn potage.
Yeah, corn potage.
What?
I come back with another super recommendation, everybody.
For my trip in Japan.
For your next trip in Japan.
This is my super recommendation.
Oh wait, oh yeah, hold on.
Wait, where did I just send that?
Okay, good.
I just sent it to myself.
I got this drink so many times and then I would see more.
more people getting it later on i was like oh yeah this is
this is the song of the summer baby did i just write the
song of the summer yes this stuff is so delicious and you
wouldn't think because it's just the almond drink this one's
the original but then they have the three nut version which
they both taste the same This almond drink was, oh my gosh,
I probably have, if I had blood, my blood would be almond.
It's so delicious.
And I looked at it, I kept seeing it for a while, and I was
like, I was like, that has a good vibe.
I think it's probably yummy.
It's so good.
Is this the new jelly addiction?
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, but almond milk, almond milk,
almond milk, yes.
Oh my God, it was so yummy.
Vibes-based milk selection.
It literally was that.
I was like, this looks like it tastes delicious.
I just, it had an aura about it.
And then I tried it and I was like, yo, it's so good.
full of sugar.
I don't care.
It's delicious.
It's so yummy.
It has like so nutty taste.
Then she drank that aura.
It has one day's worth of vitamin E.
Does it really?
Oh, it does say that.
Yeah, it has one day's worth of vitamin E.
It's good for you.
Asterisk.
Nut, nut, nut, nut, nut.
I don't usually like almond milk.
But this?
So good.
It's so good.
It's my newest recommendation.
Sookioki happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday.
Full of...
E.
E, E, E, E.
I'm in Japan for the first time.
Where should I visit Minto?
Oh my gosh, everywhere.
Go wherever your heart desires.
Go down that back alley.
Discover places.
She just left Japan with nuts.
Did Vicky turn you on to any tease?
She was like...
tea and I tried it it just like it just tasted like normal
black tea am I crazy
it tasted like a normal black tea straight York in it no
don't
let Vicky hear you say that I know this is a safe space you
can say it thank you it just Tasted like normal black tea,
and then she put cream in it, which was delicious.
Like, I like black tea.
Don't get me wrong.
It's just black tea, but it's real good black tea.
Oh.
Really?
I will be telling Vicky.
That's okay.
I have a picture of her keyboard.
I have a defense.
she cannot do anything to hurt me I have a picture of her
keyboard it's my it's my defense I cast dusty proof let me
see hold on I still have it right wait where is it thinking
of the dust I'm thinking of the dust.
Den sets a nuclear deterrent.
Yeah.
Hold on, let me drink some more tea.
Yes, I have my photo proof.
I have my photo proof.
The one good thing, though, about staying in Japan for...
extra days is that I was able to see the cherry blossoms
blooming um they weren't blooming everywhere but there were
some areas that they were let me see, hold on, let me upload
some photos uh
not that one this one this one?
this one?
that felt just like my Japanese anime.
It was really nice.
So I got to just walk around a little sick and look at the
cherry blossoms.
Seems like you had a great time.
But did you get Baskin Robbins with Phoebe?
Oh, the day that I was leaving, or thought I was originally
leaving,
um the day that i thought i was leaving uh i messaged
steiner and i was like steiner this location there is a
baskin robbins you take because their flight was later than
mine um which maybe i should have flown with them but you
know whatever i was like you take her you get Phoebe her
Baskin Robbins you make sure that she has it and you make
sure that it is delicious and she enjoys it and then later I
I got a message from Phoebe and she said Baskin Robbins get
and I was like yippee but the cherry blossoms are so nice oh
wait I upload the right photo wait is this the one I put on
Twitter?
I don't remember.
Yeah, that's the one I put on Twitter.
They were, they were blooming.
They were blooming.
My camera is not so great, but it's great at close-ups.
Not so great with, um, long shots.
Like this.
Yeah.
The cherry blossoms.
I was like, wow, and it's a nice sunny day.
That's what they call managing up.
Good job.
Turn the pick into a postcard and send it to Vicky like a
mobster's threat.
Right?
I know your secret on the back for extra points.
Yeah, I have to get clippings from like different magazines
and newspapers for the letters and spell out.
I know your secret.
Yeah.
So, this was nice, this little area.
I just kind of sat in the park.
Look how beautiful!
Look how cute they are.
They're so cute, no?
I know what you did in your arcade last summer.
Yeah, they were so pretty.
Yeah.
like what do i what do i do it's my not last or it's my last
day but i'm sick i also tried going around gotcha pond for
the metal gear gotcha pond stuff but i could not find any
sad
my favorite flower is a hydrangea yeah park is perfect it
was nice it was really it was a nice sunny day yeah yeah uh
so that was basically my trip from hell there's some other
things that happened that i can't quite say that i'm like
godly what a what a trip this was blue archive was great too
yeah it was so fun that was a hell of a setup um i brought a
uh capture like a portable capture card to capture my ipad
it did not work and then um i tried to do the steam version
it did not work because i was it was just like no you're in
japan you can't play the game the only thing that worked was
using my personal phone so i was i was sweating bullets I
was I was so scared I was like oh my god oh my god but I
have to do the sponsor I was I was stressing it was very
scary I was stressing about many things this trip yeah I was
I was doing everything to try and get and what sucks is my
worked at home so yeah you deserve a true vacation with no
sickness oh
would do not deserve disturb keep away notice yes and that's
what i did but for some reason it turned off in the middle
of the stream i don't know why i i touch nothing i have no
idea why it turned off and and luckily only a discord friend
notification popped up which what the hell man luckily
luckily it was just that but oh my my phone number also got
compromised on this trip and I have been I have been
receiving spam phone calls non-stop the entire trip and
Like, like, so, many, many calls.
And, and, um, yeah.
So I was like, oh my gosh, what if something calls?
You know, anything like that.
Oh.
Yeah, I think a company sold it or something.
Who knows?
I hadn't been getting spam calls for so, I don't know, the
last time I got one, and now I get them every day.
Even, like, multiple times a day sometimes.
I got one earlier while I was napping.
How is your trip getting worse?
Yeah, I got very lucky that nothing incriminating popped up
on my personal phone during the sponsored stream.
I was very scared.
I was very, very scared.
Scary.
Very scary.
Yeah.
Sorry, I just really wanted to hear your voice.
My voicemail.
I'm going to change my voicemail to...
Stop!
I did not sign up for this!
Please!
Please, leave me alone!
I booked a cheap hotel and they sold my number immediately
so I canceled it.
Crazy!
That's actually crazy.
A hotel?
Uh...
Ugh.
In Japan, no way.
No way!
But yeah, so, I'm glad that the Blue Archive thing went
smoothly.
But it very much could not have.
It, there was a there was a very There was a possibility of
it going extremely bad.
So.
Yeah.
I was professional.
I tried to be it.
There was actually very many things that I had to follow.
So I was very nervous.
I was like, okay, don't say this.
Okay, don't say that.
Okay.
I had to play it really safe
I didn't seem nervous on stream That's good I was also I was
like constantly having to mute to cough and everything I was
like I hope I hope this is okay But
I'm glad that I did like the way I was able to do the
Denzatsu off and the karaoke and ASMR.
It's funny, like I'm so okay with doing ASMR in hotels for
some reason.
Maybe because outside of my cafe can get quite noisy.
So I'm always nervous about doing it.
Oh yeah!
Ayami concert.
Fatal frame.
There were tech issues and tight rules in addition to you
being super sick.
Couldn't tell you did an amazing job.
Thank you.
It can and never notice from stream.
Oh yeah.
I have very I have many neighbors that like to blast music.
And they're bass and everything you put on a good show
despite being sick thank you oh my gosh Ayami concert was
also so nerve-wracking because you know I remember I was
like I was like okay I am coughing so much we are singing I
cannot like I cannot clear my throat or like cough wow
people are singing you know what I mean so I was a little
bit suffering in silence I was like okay I must suppress
everything I
thought I had practiced the songs but I forgot one song to
practice and totally messed up apart and so we had to switch
the lines at the last second.
Yeah, it was tough.
But I really liked the studio we worked with.
They were very nice.
Yeah, I just swallowed the coughs.
The live felt extra live.
It was live.
What do you mean?
It was live!
So...
Yes, but extra.
I think because we were so giggly and silly, we had, like, a
really fun time, a really silly situation that happened
during rehearsal that, um...
That, uh...
Made us feel really goofy.
I felt really bad, though, that I couldn't participate in,
like, the ASMR or the...
Um...
The...
Everyone popping through the graphics.
Yeah, it was so fun.
It was really fun to meet my sisters.
I met Sochan and Toiki and Heru-Shi.
Yeah, and Sleepy got to call in.
The Ayami family.
Ayami family.
Love the meows!
Oh my gosh, I can't stop meowing recently.
I can't stop...
I can't stop being like...
Forever meow!
I wanna be forever meow!
Do you really want to meow forever?
And ever...
Forever meow!
I would be in the shower and I would be like, I want to be
forever meow!
That's what I would do.
Just meowing away.
Forever meowing.
It's a weirdly catchy brain rot.
I know, right?
I don't know why.
I think I'm going to make a song called Forever Meal.
Once you start, you just can't stop meowing.
But I'm trying to just think of what kind of song I want it
to be.
Maybe like a Eurobeat song.
Forever Meow.
Mugen Meow.
Eurobeat.
Don't stop a meow.
Glad you're back, Vito.
I hope you take care of these next few days.
Thank you.
It was my birthday last week.
Happy birthday, Lance.
Multiplayer Portal 2 win?
Probably.
Whenever...
Vicky is back.
Probably.
Miro, B-E-P, meow.
Deja, meow.
I think I've meowed in this place before.
Yeah.
So next month sometime.
Probably.
Yeah, probably.
do you guys want to play a game you guys want to play the
the voice game voice zoo game while i'm sicky longest
pre-games that to ever not ever but billy joel we didn't
stop them yowing little little little little little little
little We're yours to come to streaming.
My songs, yes.
Eventually.
Also, I know I sound so sick, but it does not hurt to talk.
You should watch the extras when you have a chance.
They're so good.
The extras.
Meow.
Oh, meow.
Let me set it up.
Meow, meow, meow.
Wait, one second.
Oh, one second.
Oh, good thing I didn't have to knock it over.
Oh.
Meow, meow, meow.
I kind of think it's like I'm in the seat now.
I don't know why.
We can just play for a little bit.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
If you like the BGM, please go watch on the Den Zetsu
channel.
Is this the part where she kills us?
you guys know this my voice zoo there we go oh easy I had it
already set up this is the zoo I get to take care of
starting today I'm Lucy Lucy Lucy but I have to make the
animal sounds myself that's a little weird but it does sound
kind of fun I thought it maybe would be kind of funny to
play this when I'm sick the animals might sound a little
silly oh we can adopt what is that what is that oh floats
just fine on the water but on land looks like it had a few
drinks it's a loon it's a duck I saw so many ace combat
cosplayers at carry a con I wish I could share it with you
during the meet-and-greet but I was in a to go home no
you're good done thank you turning the page meowing each and
every day let's meow it's a meow meow
meow oh meow oh god yeah it's so loud
i can re-record right meow meow
Oh, meow!
Wait, let's go see our meal.
Click on an animal to move it.
Meow!
Nice.
What else can we adopt?
We can adopt.
This looks like...
Armadillo!
It's a shape.
Meow.
So close.
Now I know what Air treats will sound like tonight.
Sway trains are made of leaves.
Can I make that my alarm?
Of course.
Sway trains are made of leaves.
Why is it cut off every time?
Now we have...
Oh god.
Do you think anybody is gonna come to my zoo?
We're making bank though right now.
This is a monkey.
No!
This is a goat.
How did they not fall off the cliffs?
The goat.
I'm gonna actually try with this one.
Wait.
Sorry.
I was trying to make like a...
That's a better sound.
Oh god, it just keeps repeating.
It's terrifying.
This looks like a cat.
Oh, it's a fox.
I'm gonna do...
I'm gonna do five Nights at Freddy's.
Wow!
Wait, how is this to do the...
What does the fox say?
Ring, ring, ring, ring, ring.
You know, after Zanzibar, no way, that's too good.
Gray fox.
Is it?
Do you spell gray fox with an E or an A?
Do you spell gray with an E or an A?
What is this one?
Wait, how's...
I was trying to do the FNAF sound when it jumpscares at you.
and it's like...
I
think the...
Gray is a color.
Gray is name.
So what if A for that guy?
Okay.
E is British.
A is US.
Oh.
I kind of like it though.
We'll do another one with that sound effect.
This one will say, did you know that Jaeger is Wait, what
you would...
Wait, it's not Frank.
Did you know that Jaeger is...
Hunter, in German.
Frank for Hunter.
Did you know that Jaeger is...
Wait, oh, dang it, one more time.
Did you know that Jaeger is German for Hunter?
Oh, no!
Did you know that dagger is German for...
I
think I'll keep it.
Did you know that dagger is German?
God, this is a hell zoo.
Is this a penguin?
Oh, it is!
Penguin.
There's a penguin.
I don't know.
That would be good too.
Wait, hold on.
Sorry, I've really got to clear.
my throat real quick.
I'll do a do-do.
I'll try again.
Oh,
the single newt.
The single newt.
Okay, let's do that one.
Sweet dreams are on the moon.
Why did I do that?
That could be kind of walrus.
I'm going to do a really good voice for this one.
Well, I'll tell you what.
I have to do...
I have to do one without laughing.
I'll tell you what.
I think that's good.
What
should his name be?
Hank?
Oh.
I'll tell you what.
What else we got?
Apex Predator.
Oh, is this a polar bear?
Oh, it's so cute!
The Minto VA arc begins here.
It already began!
Look at this guy.
Satan, I'm just satin!
I'm just satin!
Satin, I'm just satin!
I don't know.
There was actually a King of the Hill episode where Hank
Hill's friends thought he was an experiment to turn them
into a walrus human hybrid.
No way.
Satan!
I'm just sitting!
Sitin!
Actually, no, I'm going to do a real growl with this one.
No.
It was Hank's friend.
Is that better?
Thank you so much for the vibe, Gifton.
It's been real Japari Park, but there's...
New moai zoo to see.
I'm just sitting.
I'm sitting.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Sitting.
I'm just sitting.
I'm sitting.
That's good.
Sitting bear.
Sitting.
I'm just sitting.
I'm sitting.
Meese?
Reindeer.
Doofus.
Wait.
All the other reindeer say.
Wait, what did they say?
Wait, how's that song go?
Rudolph the Red.
Oh, it's reindeer.
Then one foggy Christmas Eve.
Wait.
It's me.
Doofus.
It's Doofus.
It's me!
It's Dufus!
You'd even say it glows like a light bulb!
Is that how it goes?
You'd even say it glows like a...
Nah, we'll go back to...
I'm Dufus.
That's good.
That one's pretty good, actually.
It's a... He literally is a reindeer it said he's a reindeer
what do i put them all together
summoning circle
never tell a secret
Oh oh I know I know I know metal glass wait no no I want one
more metal glass crack metal shrock
shrock wario metal shrock warrior metal
uh clask clask metal Blask.
Metal.
Shrug.
Oh, that's good.
That's good.
Oh, he's so far.
Blask.
I'm never going to see him again.
Hello.
I don't...
Everything is free roaming here.
Oh, me.
Blask.
Metal.
Shrug.
What else do we got over here?
Huh?
We're making...
Big bucks right now.
Oh, the Echo Cave.
Oh, we gotta unlock the...
We have the Sahara.
Oh, it's a big old circle.
And then there was another area to unlock.
Oh, God.
Flamingo!
Why she looks so sexy, though?
Sexy flamingo.
Why does she look so sexy though?
She even gives you the eyes when she says it.
Why is my laugh like that?
I'm like, oh.
She's a baddie.
Yeah, she is.
Why I look so sexy though?
Why?
Why I look so sexy, though.
Thankfully, sitting bear is just always sitting.
Otherwise, it might be a slight issue.
So true.
Okay, I changed it instead of her to me.
So it's like the sexy flamingo.
It's like, why am I so sexy?
Why I look so sexy, though.
I'm like laughing and laughing at least.
Oh, God.
Oh, an owl!
Owl, you glad I didn't say orange?
The jokester.
He's the jokester.
The jorker.
Yeah, it's good, it's good, it's good.
It's good, it's good.
oh okay must be a hobby hovering up and we're getting lots
of birds now this one's america this one's america america
oh canada oh i try to say oh canada
yo me don't miss you thank you
what a metal gear quote why don't there's There's no eagles
in Metal Gear.
It's like a Pokemon, it says its name.
There we'll do.
It's like, oh, oh, no.
America, oh, oh, oh, oh, loo, loo, loo, loo,
eagle.
Oh, so true.
But the eagle flies higher above the clouds.
I had to do it kind of fast.
But the eagle flies higher above the cloud.
Good enough.
It's so true.
Oh my god.
This is...
What is this one?
A lion!
Rar.
I always wanted a brother.
I always wanted a breather.
I always
wanted a breather.
Brutta.
I always wanted a breather.
Mufasha.
Meow.
We gotta get away from the meow.
I don't have enough money.
Keep talking, keep talking.
I look so sexy though.
Come on.
I always wanted a brother.
Yeah, I always wanted a brother.
I always wanted a brother at the watering hole.
I look so sexy though.
Yeah.
And Draco's thank you.
Flies higher above the glass.
I look so sexy though.
You guys get it?
Yeah.
Okay, we're gonna put meow like far.
Meow.
Oh my god.
Meow is terrible.
Okay, I might have enough.
Yeah!
How many animals are there?
Oh, there's not so many.
We'll get this.
We'll get, we got this.
Oh, Rhino.
Meow should go in the middle.
Meow too Meow Meow Wee Forever meow I wanna be Forever meow
I wanna be It's a loop Forever meow I wanna be forever meow
I wanna be Forever meow I wanna be
Meow I wanna be forever meow Do you really want to meow
forever?
Wait!
I could have them all go Do you really want... I could sing
the whole song.
Wait.
So, forever meow I want to be... Okay.
Forever meow I want to be...
Okay, see you.
Alright, this is...
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I always wanted to breathe that.
Okay...
Okay, next guy is gonna be...
Okay, yeah.
Elephant.
Okay.
Forever, meow.
Do you really want to...
Do you really...
Do you really want to meow forever?
Do you really want to meow forever loops are eternal yeah
all right move faster you need to shut up shut up shut up
you're ruining no no you have to go first and then second go
go Your timing is all off.
I'm going to kick you out of this course.
What was this?
All the animals at the camp sing at once.
One.
Wait, the animals at the camp sing one by one from left to
right.
Oh.
It's higher above the clap.
Okay, hold on.
Oh my god, oh my god, this might be it.
This might be it.
Maybe we gotta do it with the birds though.
Alright, sing.
Oh, how cute!
Dark enthusiast!
This is a reindeer.
Cat!
We gotta be a cat, girl.
But I think the duck one is the cutest.
Actually, why is this just Takanashi Kiara?
This is literally Kiara.
What the heck?
Froggy Yawa!
Sorry.
Why don't they sing?
Maybe I have to...
Maybe I have to get everybody...
All of them filled out, you know?
I always wanted a bridge.
Hello?
Oh, press space.
Why I look so sexy, though.
I want to meow forever.
Why I look so sexy though.
But the eagle flies higher above the camera.
Okay, cool.
Let's get another animal.
This is Sayonauta but the guy hears the world.
Don't noise.
Okay.
Do you really want to meow?
out forever endeavor endeavor
endeavor endeavor okay endeavor endeavor come on come here,
come here come here yeah yeah okay we got this you glad I
didn't say oh endeavor I never!
We'll take this guy back to his home.
This is great!
This is working perfectly!
Okay, perfect.
to meow forever and ever and ever all right perfect
blask all right now we gotta buy another guy no no no i need
i need tons of money Did you know that Yeager is German
for...
Wait, I just noticed, too, what is this car?
Is this me?
Is there a story here?
No, no, sitting.
I'm just sitting.
I'm sitting.
I'll tell you what.
You can re-record for cheap.
Oh, okay, cool.
I'll just do new people, though.
How much is it, though?
Ow.
Oh, I guess I go to the guy.
Oh, re-record for 20.
Oh, okay, okay.
It's not bad.
You glad I didn't say orange?
I feel like I should...
I didn't know that we could do it like this, so now I kind
of want to...
Okay, hold on.
You really want to meow forever?
Why I look so sexy, though.
Okay, this guy.
Oh, 210!
Why was it so expensive?
Holy cow.
Never mind.
Uh, okay.
Um...
I want to be here for it Forever I want to be here for
Forever For ever meow I want to be Forever meow I want to be
Okay I look so sexy though And we'll have him say forever
meow And then do you really want to meow forever?
I look so sexy though.
Forever meow.
I want to be...
Do you really want to meow forever?
And ever.
Nice.
Shrock.
All right here we go.
Here we go.
Oh he's so cute!
Forever meow.
Oh.
How will you go?
How will you say orange?
Here we go.
Forever meow.
Orange.
What the eagle?
Forever meow.
Okay, here we go.
Do you really want to meow forever?
And ever.
Yeah!
Our chorus!
Forever Meow I want to be forever Meow Do you really want to
meow forever?
And ever.
Yeah, he's chomping on his butt.
That's okay though.
I think that's great.
Now we can get back to our regularly scheduled
This is a tiger.
Nice producing, thank you.
I always wanted a breather.
This one's good though.
Say it again.
I always wanted a breather.
I always wanted a brother.
What did you want?
He always wanted one.
I always wanted a brother.
Do they still make money in the chorus?
I think they still...
Wow, I look so sexy though.
Oh, they do, I have to play it though.
I look so sexy though.
They don't just sing on their own, oh no!
And ever.
Oh no!
Okay, we're gonna have to take them off then.
I look so sexy though.
Well, they'll just sing together in their hearts.
Wow, I look so sexy though.
Wow.
Yeah.
There's a plane here too!
Do you really want to meow?
No, I gotta put them in their habitat!
I'm a good... I'm a good... I take good care of the animals.
Meow.
I'm not the cat rock.
Meow!
Do you really want to meow forever?
Aww!
I want to forever!
Perfect, perfect, perfect.
Okay, who else have we got?
Alright, now we're making super money.
This one I feel like I have to.
Oh wow!
He kind of looks like Tony the Tiger, doesn't he?
Tony.
Yeah, Tiger!
They're great!
Hmm.
So when is this zoo going to be open to the public?
I need to enter you as soon as possible.
You want to lose your marbles?
Keep them in a bag so you don't lose them.
I was a VTuber and then they...
The cliffhanger.
The cliffhanger!
What?
I always wanted a breather.
Forever meow What's this guy?
Was this a monkey?
Oh my god Thank you
Oh shoot I meant to play it instead Oh shoot No
I meant to record Instead!
Oh, oh, shu-touch.
Keep it!
Okay.
Oh, oh, shu-touch.
Why did I say it like that?
I want to go into the caves!
Oh, oh, shu-touch.
Oh, 6,000 coins.
Oh shoot.
We can purchase.
Oh the reindeer's so cute.
Oh god I want the duck costume though.
It's so cute.
Wait so if I put it on.
How do I put it on?
How do I put you on?
Oh here's where we unlock them.
Oh here we go.
Oh no.
Wait, oh, oh, no, wait, oh, I forgot!
The outfit's so cute, though, but it's evil.
It's evil.
No, no.
I'm sorry to get sleepy, guys.
The jet lag is winning.
It really is winning.
I don't stand a chance.
I feel like we need more animals
Why I look so sexy though?
What is this guy?
Cuteness solves everything.
A panda!
Only a true zookeeper can encounter this being.
The final guest.
Oh, maybe they added more.
Panda.
What noise does a panda make?
Is it kind of like a...
Like a...
Like that?
Jack Black.
Uh...
Uh, wait.
I've never seen Kung Fu Panda.
Um...
Uh, hold on.
Skadoosh.
My name is Steve.
Oh, wait, here's the end.
Oh, he says, I am Steve.
I am Steve.
Oh, yeah.
Check-in, Jackie.
No, I don't want to laugh in it.
I'll do, I am Steve.
I am Steve Whoa that was good That was good What sound is
Kung Fu Wait hold on I'm gonna look up Famous Kung Fu Panda
quote I'm looking it up It's Po right
It Po is the bear right The panda Right Skadoosh
None of these are interesting.
Oh he does say!
Skadoosh!
Flit and steal!
Thy nether.
Can I say it right?
Forever meow.
He didn't even say it.
Yeah, I've never seen the Kung Fu Panda before.
Skeddish.
Iconic line from Nacho Libre.
Ferever.
Miao?
Famous quotes in Nacho Libre.
Skedish.
Skeddish.
When you wear a man, sometimes you wear stretchy pants in
your room.
It's for fun.
Okay, we got so much money in the house.
Let's go.
What the heck is...
Oh, the sloth!
Oh!
The sloth!
Meow.
I didn't mean to record.
Oh.
Yeah.
I think from now on, whatever I do first will be what I go
with, you know?
No re-records.
Yeah.
It's forever meow.
Oh, why did I say that like that?
Oh, what is this thing?
Oh, this is a frog.
Mint on the first take.
Hello, Canada.
Oh, it's Greetings, Canada.
I'm a fraud.
Fraud!
And he is a frog.
this is such a random assortment of creatures in this area
oh what was this one oh shoot oh shoot
I always wanted a brother.
Oh, he's always wanted a brother!
I'll tell you what.
I'm beautiful.
Wait.
Did you know that dagger is German for...
How will you glad I didn't say orange?
Flask.
Hello.
I always wanted a brother.
I always wanted a breath.
Do you really want to meow?
Guys, the jet lag is winning.
What do I do?
Oh, oh shoot.
Oh shoot.
What do I do?
Oh, oh shoot.
I don't want to get all the animals though.
Is this a dog?
Wait, it spins its tail like a helicopter.
Oh!
It's a dog!
Woof!
Those names woof?
Can you pet the dog?
Let's see.
Sweet dreams are made of...
Oh shit.
What the dog doing?
He's barking.
Woof!
It's hard for me to keep my eyes open.
You can shake the dog.
What the heck?
No way!
Oh
my god!
Swear, trains are made up of me!
Swear...
Oh, done is the name of the dog.
Oh, I can actually name the dog.
It sounded like I said shit instead.
Oh, oh, shit.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
I'm going to put him on the campfire.
Yeah, I want him to be a hot dog.
It is.
oh gosh you guys i don't know if i'm gonna make it i might i
might have to go pass out
i thought i was gonna have to take us well i will still take
the medicine is it okay if i go asleep sorry for the shorter
stream I'm not gonna make it!
I'm not gonna make it!
I'm gonna fall asleep right here!
I'll fall asleep right next to Doug.
I mean meow.
Meow.
Will you glad I didn't say orange?
You're so annoying.
Oh, you're so annoying.
Live sleep stream.
Yeah, I'm gonna fall asleep right now.
I always wanted a brother.
I always quit the game.
Good night everybody.
Good night.
Thank you.
Early, early.
I'm going to bed.
Good night.